hello it's seven o'clock this is Sky
News breakfast these are our top stories
here this morning the threat of
political violence as the husband of the
U.S House speaker Nancy Pelosi is
attacked in his home by a man asking
where's Nancy
first of good conscience
he's the clearly and unambiguously
up against the violence in our policy
Twitter's new owner Elon Musk promises a
shake-up with the platform offering
widely diverse viewpoints
bubble
a speech crisis how covid-19 has led to
more children struggling to talk and
understand words
Sky News learns how the ministry of
Defense sent serving RAF pilots on
training missions to China and allowed
Chinese Nationals to study at UK
military academies
[Music]
the original wild man of rock
controversial rock and roll Pioneer
Jerry Lee Lewis dies at the age of 87.
in the sport Red Bull denied cheating in
F1 after being fined and given sporting
sanctions for breaking coscap rules
the weather outbreaks of rain will
gradually move northwards today heaviest
in the west still mild in fact very warm
in the sunshine in the southeast
and as of course too we'll go through
the papers with journalist Janelle
aldred and Anthropologist Mariana hotter
foreign
good morning the U.S President Joe Biden
has spoken out against political
violence after the husband of the U.S
House speaker Nancy Pelosi was attacked
in the couple's home the Intruder
reportedly shouted where is Nancy before
attacking Paul Pelosi with a hammer Mrs
Pelosi is the third most senior
politician in America and the incident
comes amid heightened political tensions
ahead of the midterm elections our U.S
correspondent Mark Stone reports
of a government jet which had brought
her from Washington the U.S House
speaker was whisked away to the hospital
in San Francisco where her husband is
being treated
it is a Wonder Paul Pelosi survived the
ordeal here inside their home in the
early hours of Friday morning
as the attacker entered through this
door breaking the glass with a hammer Mr
Pelosi who is 82 and was alone inside
managed to call 9-1-1 a dispatcher
praised for interpreting the urgency of
an unclear call
when officers arrived at just before 2
30 in the morning they witnessed the
attack
this was not a random act this was
intentional
and it's wrong
our elected officials are here to do the
business of their cities their counties
their states and this nation
their families don't sign up for this to
be harmed
and it is wrong
the suspect who has been named as 42
year old David de Pepe tried to tie Mr
Pelosi up and told officers at the scene
we're waiting for Nancy Nancy Pelosi is
the third most senior politician in
America second in line to the presidency
after the Vice President she is among
the most prominent of Democratic party
figures and a key supporter of Joe Biden
the chant was
Nancy where's Nancy where's Nancy
this is Despicable
there's no place in America
there's too much violence political
violence
too much hatred
too much vitriol
the political climate here right now is
tense with the midterm elections just
over a week away the nation is bitterly
dangerously divided and those false
claims of a stolen election well they
linger and they agitate we don't yet
know precisely what the motive was for
this attack but the fact remains it is
the second time in two years that
speaker Pelosi has been the Target
on the 6th of January last year she was
evacuated from her office on Capitol
Hill moments before a mob arrived
[Music]
security at their San Francisco home
wasn't High because speaker Pelosi
wasn't there a review will now consider
whether family members of high-profile
politicians do need protection too it
comes at a time when authorities are
warning the threat of targeted political
violence is growing Mark Stone Sky News
in Washington
Navy has ordered an investigation into
allegations of inappropriate behavior in
the submarine service a number of women
have come forward to speak publicly
about sexual bullying in the service
Admirals of NK the first Sea Lord said
sexual assault and harassment has no
place in the Royal Navy he said that
anyone who's found culpable will be held
accountable regardless of rank
another man has been questioned about
the murder of nine-year-old Olivia Pratt
Corbell who was shot dead at her home in
Liverpool in August he was arrested
yesterday suspected of assisting an
offender Thomas Cashman has been charged
with Olivia's murder and is due in court
again next year
floods and landslides set off by
tropical storm now guy have killed more
than 70 people in the Philippines the
worst affected areas are in the South
where as many as a 60 are missing in one
Village buried in a deluge of rainwater
mud and trees
Elon Musk says those people who've been
banned from Twitter will now face a
Content moderation Council to have their
profiles reinstated the billionaire
owner has faced floods of requests from
banned account holders and world leaders
following the completion of his 38
billion pound takeover of the platform
our U.S correspondent Martha Kellner
reports
the world's richest man is now in
control of one of its most influential
communication platforms let that sink in
after a month's long will he won't he
Saga Elon Musk buying Twitter for 44
billion dollars let the good times roll
he tweeted musk wasted no time making
his Mark even before this takeover had
been officially announced the chief
executive and Chief Financial Officer
was shuttled from the building behind me
and told not to return it is a sign of
just how fundamentally he plans to
change things here
and among his remaining staff mixed
feelings I'm half excited
half scared like I'm excited for you
know the new leadership and obviously
Twitter I struggle to make money
um with good monetization strategies so
I think I'm excited to see what he will
turn Twitter into but I'm stressed about
you know all the chaos it's gonna bring
in and what does it mean for our
day-to-day work and like
um
what does it mean for work balance what
does it mean for some people getting
laid off chaos it's fair to say is
expected musk believes more free speech
in his own words is what's needed on
Twitter that could involve reinstating
the account of former president Donald
Trump but for now musk says there's no
movement on that front Twitter will be
forming a Content moderation council
with widely diverse viewpoints he wrote
no major content decisions or account
reinstatements will happen before that
Council convenes he says he wants half
the world on his website but some are
unconvinced he's fascinating he's uh you
know infuriating he's brilliant
um but I'm not sure that I want um him
in control of you know a fairly large
platform and Twitter's not the biggest
platform in social media in the world
and it's probably at its it's uh maybe
it's best days are behind it but still
the fact that one man controls it I
think is uh you know as a matter for
concern for all of us
so it's even harder to predict Martha
kellner's Sky News San Francisco
development experts say that the UK is
now spending more of its International
Development budget at home than in
developing countries the center for
Global development says a large
proportion of the part is being spent on
housing refugees mainly from Ukraine
let's bring in our politics and
correspondent Amanda acasses in
Westminster for us this morning and
Amanda some people might be quite
surprised to hear that so much money is
spent at home of an international Aid
budget
yes indeed it does sound rather
extraordinary doesn't it if we look at
the breakdown of this the total budget
is 11 billion pounds but 4 billion of
that is sent directly to multilateral
organizations like the World Bank
leaving 7 billion which the UK
government directly decides how to spend
it and it's more than half of that which
it turns out is being spent housing
refugees here in the UK many of them of
course from Ukraine leaving less money
to go around on the kind of projects
that people might imagine it's being
spent on helping countries that are less
developed overseas now overall the
budget is capped at 0.5 percent of
national income that was slashed by a
third it used to be 0.7 that decision
was taken by Rishi sunak now prime
minister of course when he was
Chancellor because of the cost of covet
but he did pledge
um to get it back up to 0.7 by 2024. now
given the fact that the government have
been saying that the chancellor in prime
minister are looking to fill a 50
billion pound budgetary black hole with
a combination of spending cuts and tax
increases it looks increasingly likely
that that pledge might not be fulfilled
the telegraph reporting this morning Mr
sunac has already decided to freeze
spending in this area politically it
could be quite difficult because the
minister he's appointed in charge of
this Andrew Mitchell is one of the MPS
who actually rebelled against the
decision to cut spending when that was
taken during covid now the government
continues to insist that the UK is one
of the largest overseas donors in the
world but I think this is yet another
decision which really highlights how
pressures domestically on the economy
are affecting our Global standing
overseas particularly after that call
not to attend the climate conference in
Egypt as well
Amanda thanks very much indeed
well Richie sunac has been criticized
for reappointing suela bravam and his
Home Secretary just six days after Liz
truss forced her out for breaching the
ministerial code and now experts are
questioning where her Hardline approach
leads the UK's immigration policy well
joining me now to discuss all of this is
Mo Hussein who's a former advisor to
Amber Rudd when she was Home Secretary
uh saying good morning to you nice to
talk to you this morning and
of all what kind of a week has it been
for Richie sunak is first as a prime
minister and to what extent have the
headlines around swella Brava been a fly
in the ointment
they've certainly been a thorn inside of
the first few days of his Premiership
um I think he started off he started off
well because ultimately he was
Vindicated all the things he said about
the list trust plan for the economy
unfortunately have come true
unfortunately I say for the state of the
economic conditions around the country
but um he he has been the one who called
it out and hopefully he will now have a
plan to correct that so I think that
hugely goes in his favor this
reappointment though has raised
questions about his own judgment on the
steps of dining Street he spoke a lot
about integrity and professionalism in
government in an attempt to draw some
clear water between himself and the
previous Johnson Administration but this
has led people to question how how far
why he actually meant that reappointing
somebody who was found breaching the
ministry will go to six days before I
think if you take a step back though
this is really about uh trying to
construct a cabinet from all sides of
the party and particularly the pro
brexit right to the party whose sport he
does need to try and govern effectively
well yes I mean presumably Unity is very
important we've seen how much fracturing
there's been during the various
leadership campaigns
how effective can he be at holding the
party together though we read in this
morning's papers in the eye newspaper
suggesting that there's a push from his
own supporters to crack down on the
rights of the party and sax Wella
bravaman How likely is that
well this will be a real challenge for
him going forward and it's almost like
he's walking a political tightrope
because a party is so vast now in terms
of if you look at the more traditional
Southern seats the conservative had held
for a long time then you look at the new
parts that were won in 2019 where the
Prime Minister will want to retain these
seats going forward then you have the
moderate One Nation wing and also the
ERG and everything in between that and
so you're trying to keep lots and lots
of people happy and you have you have
got their support and in in putting as
well back in this role he's also using
immigration as a bit of a dividing line
because the economy will need a safety
first approach you won't be able to do
anything to radical it will have to be
quite mainstream so what what is the
dividing line between the government the
conservative party and the opposition so
immigration Falls quite easily into that
category and I think having somebody
inside the cabinet where they are tied
into making the decisions is always
better than having them on the back
benches when they are sniping and
complaining about things they're not
happy with involving them and making
them take some responsibility is clearly
part of his strategy here and
ideologically how close are sunak and
bravaman on the issue of immigration
she's made it very clear that she's
passionate about the Rwanda policy he's
backed that policy so are they actually
on the same page on this
I think on the surface of it it may look
like they are but there will be some
differences behind the scenes who spoke
about that in his initial leadership
campaign in the summer because
ultimately he was appealing to
conservative party members who will have
certain views on immigration and you
always feel the need to throw red meat
to to them and also to the right of the
party so they they believe in you and
they support you but actually as we
found in terms of the relationship
between list trust and Thriller problem
but not immigration I think Rishi tsuna
will probably want to see some
liberalization uh in terms of more
students perhaps coming to the UK or
certain parts of the economy uh being
able to grow and that will need
International labor so this discussion
around immigration clamping down on it
versus growing the economy is still very
live behind the scenes and uh even
though he's spending a lot of time
talking about the 20 19 Manifesto and
going back to those first principles the
economic challenge is is so vast that he
will be thinking about how do I balance
the books how do I get this black hole
down and how do we get the economy
moving and in some you know some areas
immigration will be a consideration in
that
fascinating stuff most Hussein always
interesting to get your take on things
thanks very much indeed for joining us
this morning
now pandemic lockdowns have had a
significant impact on children's
language development according to a
charity that says 1.7 million are
struggling with talking and
understanding words
speech and language UK says those Left
Behind can catch up but only with the
right tools and help Sky's Lisa Dowd
reports
[Music]
what do you want me to do Jacob has
trouble telling his mum what he wants
did you want me to move out the way
he was born at the start of the first
covid lockdown and she says it has had a
big impact on his speech and language
we didn't do a lot because we couldn't
we could go to the park we could go and
feed the Ducks
but we didn't get to see friends and
family and that would
help with like hearing different
conversations and hearing different
words and and things like that but he
didn't he didn't get to do that he is
very chatty
but I think we take for granted just how
much different social situations helps
communication Jacob can you say I
I I for insect it's not just a problem
in early years education new figures
suggest that 1.7 million school-aged
children in the UK are struggling with
talking and understanding words
following the pandemic
children can struggle with talking and
understanding words all the way through
their their school careers and actually
if we don't help them they're more
likely to fall behind in all of the core
subjects they're more likely to develop
mental health problems they're more
likely to end up in the criminal justice
system
the charity wants the government to fund
better training for teachers to help
reverse the lingering impact of covid
children lost out on lots of social
opportunities and
his parents were at home working from
home the parents might not have had the
time to kind of interact as often and it
was really a stressful time for parents
so I think it has had kind of a negative
impact but the research that I've read
shows that children will catch up so if
they're giving the right tools and early
on
ghost oh my goodness a spooky ghost the
Westminster government says they're
investing nearly 5 billion pounds to
help youngsters following the pandemic
including targeted support for pupils
who need it most
some feel that significant numbers of
children are still being failed
Lisa Dowd Sky News
an injured owl has been rescued and
cared for by a fish fishing crew a
hundred miles out at Sea off the North
Coast of Scotland a crew member came to
the rescue when they spotted the bird
being attacked by seagulls and was then
cared for by the team on board the
Barnacle 2 for the rest of their trip
it's believed the owl had been blown off
its normal calls before landing on the
boat but the crew said that it perked up
after being fed with some chopped steak
that works with my husband as well time
now for the weather
anticipation is rising I so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
well there'll be further bands of wet
and windy weather this weekend but it
does remain very mild with some sunnier
spells while much of Scotland Northern
Ireland and Northern England will start
the day on a dry note a thicker Cloud
will have brought rain to Island Wales
and Southern England cloud and outbreaks
of rain will collaterally gradually move
north today although Northern Scotland
will stay dry with some Sunny spells for
much of the day and it'll brighten up
across Southern parts of England and
it'll be warm in the sunshine in the
Southeast you're watching Sky News
breakfast now thousands of mothers will
take to the streets across the UK today
in a Halloween themed protest aimed at
pressuring the government to help
families with young children well
joining me now is the founder of
pregnant then screwed Jolie Braley along
with single mother and actress Jennifer
Greenwood and her very gorgeous dorsal
Matilda sitting there I'll be speaking
to them in a minute but Jody to you
first of all tell us why you are
protesting today
so much of the mummies is a national
protest to demand government reform on
Child Care flexible working and parental
leave
mothers feel completely let down by this
government we feel that we're being set
up to fail most households need two
incomes to survive yet we've created a
society where in many cases it's almost
impossible for many mothers to work or
certainly to work the hours that they
want to and by that I mean we have the
second most expensive child care system
in the developed world we have a
parental leave scheme that pays just 47
of the minimum wage which means that
many children have been born into
poverty or many mothers are having to
return to work before the end of their
maternity leave we've got dads only at
being able to access just two weeks of
paternity leave in some cases they can't
access any opportunity leave whatsoever
and we despite a government Manifesto
Pledge on flexible working flexible
working still hasn't been made by
default and only 10 of jobs are
advertised as part-time and of course
those most parents need flexibility in
their employment to be able to manage
their unpaid work and their paid work so
we've just created these structures and
systems that are making it really
impossible for families to be able to
survive and thrive
and and Jennifer I see you nodding there
I mean you have not not only Matilda I
think you've got another older child as
well haven't you and and it's had a real
impact on you having children and trying
to hold a job at the same time tell us
what's happened to you
so my son is three so I've got two
children under three
um I'm an actor and a teacher
um well I had my son
um I took a Year's maternity
um and by that I mean I was unpaid
um for three months of that and paid as
Jolie said
um the minimum uh the basic minimum for
the first nine months and I was lucky
enough to be supported by my husband
which throws us back into gender
stereotypes um anyway
um and my husband was only able to take
two weeks paternity like so many men
um and then I was unable to return to
the workforce as a theater actor because
I couldn't afford the childcare
um we're talking not just rehearsals in
the daytime we're talking night nannies
we're talking people who need to do
um childcare different flexible times of
the day once you introduce Freelancers
like myself into the equation you might
as well forget it because the system is
not set up to support us
um I have
um a really wonderful mother
um grandmother to the children who
drives up every Wednesday night to stay
with my daughter on a Thursday and
Friday she lives in Norfolk she's a
three-hour drive to look after Matilda
two days a week because I simply can't
afford as a teacher to put her into
Nursery
and surely the government would say we
do offer some help wouldn't they they'd
say there's free child care for 30 hours
a week up to 30 hours a week for three
and four-year-olds and a range of
schemes depending on whether you're on
universal credit or tax credits they
would say they are offering support
for those children that are under three
yeah but I mean this is the problem so
when maternity leave finishes or
parental leave finishes the child care
system is so extortionately expensive it
costs on average 14 000 pounds a year to
put your child into child care so most
and it tends to be mothers look at the
cost of child care and then compare it
to their income and they think hold on a
minute that just really isn't worth me
working why am I paying to go to work in
some cases and so they fall out of the
workforce and actually the government
does keep saying we're investing loads
of money in child care but compared to
other countries we are not we are way
below with the countries in terms of
percentage of GDP and we've got to
remember that this is an investment it's
not a cost time and time again the
research shows that if you invest in
child care you get more back into the
economy than you put in if you look well
Canada has just done they've invested 30
billion dollars in their child care
sector to create a system that costs no
more more than ten dollars a day and
they've done that because they've found
that for every dollar they invested in
child care they got between 1.50 to 2.80
back into the wider economy you know our
politicians keep talking about growth
but we will never have growth unless we
can Liberate the power and the skills of
women and the system that we have at the
moment means that women are leaving the
workforce in droves right in the middle
of a skills crisis right in the middle
of a cost of living crisis when we need
that money the most
okay well Jolie really we appreciate
your time this morning and thanks to to
Jennifer Greenwood and and Matilda I
can't see her now I want to see her
again
she's absolutely delightful oh it's so
so gorgeous and what a great outfit that
is a pumpkin isn't it
very Halloween fantastic stuff thank you
both very much indeed for your time
thank you
now Sky News has learned that the
ministry of Defense sent serving RAF
Pilots to China to teach their
counterparts and allowed Chinese
Nationals to study at the UK's military
academies as recently as 2019. earlier
this month the government revealed that
around 30 former British military Pilots
are currently in China teaching the Air
Force how to defeat Western warplanes
well labor has said the latest
Revelations could pose a significant
threat to National Security here's our
security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes
making friends as then Prime Minister
David Cameron offered China's president
a taste of British culture
this was 2015 when a desire to do
business trumped security fears then
came the reality a Crackdown in Hong
Kong claims about human rights abuses
and threats against the island of Taiwan
with policy on China changing the UK
this month revealed some sturdy former
British military Pilots at training the
Chinese Air Force in what it described
as a threat to UK interests
but Sky News has learned the ministry of
Defense itself also helped to train the
Chinese over the years
I've been told by a source that the
ministry of Defense here behind me sent
up to four serving RAF Pilots to Beijing
in September 2016 for around three weeks
to teach what was known as the aviation
English course apparently this was about
helping Chinese Pilots learn about how
to run overseas military deployments
also at least three Chinese officers
have been allowed to go through basic
training at the raf's college in
Lincolnshire one as recently as 2019 and
a number of Chinese Nationals are
thought to have studied here as well the
more senior joint services staff College
in srivenham
a senior conservative MP was shocked I
mean this is just astonishing given the
fact that there's so concerns so many
concerns over the last uh not a couple
of years but indeed the entire decade we
should have woken up to this and we
clearly haven't
it's not just a UK problem
on a visit to a U.S aircraft carrier
operating in European Waters the head of
NATO said all allies must be aware of
China trying to use their knowledge to
gain an advantage
it is absolute an issue that we have
actually
owned the NATO agenda is how to not
share
expertise knowledge technology with a
country like like China
a spokesperson for the ministry of
Defense said the UK has never provided
fastjet Flight Training or any other
sensitive training for people's
Liberation Army Air Force pilots
but that still leaves questions about
why concerns weren't raised faster about
former Pilots going off to train the
Chinese Deborah Haynes Sky News
so it's time to turn our attention to
the newspapers here with me to review
them this morning are the Anthropologist
Mariana hotter and the journalist and
author Janelle Aldridge so welcome back
to both of you and we're going to dive
inside the papers this hour we dealt
with a few of the front pages last time
around but Janelle you've picked out a
double page spread in the Daily Mirror
um which has got a fantastic picture of
Rishi sunak visiting a hospital and
there is a woman literally wagging her
finger at him
yeah she told him to try harder when it
comes to nurses pay and I think that's
something that many of us and and many
people agree with 79 of people believe
there are not enough nurses to deliver
safe NHS care and that's something that
we should all be concerned about now the
service was on its needs before covid
but the Tories have been in power for
over a decade now so this deep austerity
that they love mainly because I think a
lot of them don't feel the pinch
um I think it has put the NHS in a
really really tricky situation and so
pay it PM is is the phrase really
because in March the MPS with whaling
and gnashing of tea will take their
annual pay rise and they had a pay rise
last year and it's set by an independent
um standards Authority which is a funded
by the treasury and their budget's
approved by the speaker of the house so
the Tails wagging the dog so I think
before we get to next march the next
financial year I think people in the NHS
really want to see what other government
going to be doing for nurses pay and
that will be set again change what they
do for themselves next year it's a very
tricky one this one Marianne isn't it
because I'm sure a lot of people will be
hugely grateful for the care they always
receive when they go to the NHS but
particularly during covert being such a
tough time and yet the government is
going to have demands from every sector
isn't it for increases in wages at a
time when budgets are just so tight and
we've heard so much about tough
decisions being needed
yeah you're right I mean we don't have a
Magic Money Tree fundamentally I think
uh growth um is has to be the basis of
of our you know future Prosperity but
fundamentally I I agree with you now
austerity is a political decision
um one of the things that really struck
me when the the kind of commentary
around Liz truss and quasiquartings
failed mini budget came out was that
these were described as unfunded Cuts
well they weren't unfunded in as much as
they were going to borrow to fund them
and you could have the conversation
around whether they were making the
right kinds of tax cuts certainly but
there's a certain point at which you
know that that kind of old adage about
um you save up so you can spend it when
the rainy day comes well if there were a
rainy day it's absolutely monsoon season
now isn't it we're in the midst of an
energy crisis there's huge Global
um instability in terms of these kind of
Shifting Global powers and we're still
coming out of the the kind of the the
fractures of kobit and the global
pandemic and all the impacts on the
global Supply chains there
um whether you're a supporter or not
brexit has had an impact
that needs to be dealt with and factored
into the system and so fundamentally
maybe this is the time that actually we
do need to borrow more money okay and
and actually invest in public services
because when you undercut the teachers
the nurses the social workers the police
then you know the fabric of society
starts to to fall apart it's it's not
unsustainable and it's a huge debate of
our time isn't it at the moment and how
different parties would approach it so
um but let's move on to an international
issue which I know Marianne that you
wanted to talk about this is I'm not
even sure which paper it is it's a
telegraph actually
um but a lot of the papers will be
covering these protests in Iran
well that's the interesting thing not
that many papers are and you do have to
burrow deep into the inside pages to
find reporting about these protests that
are now right across Iran and have been
going on for 43 days since the death of
a young woman called Masa amini who uh
was murdered by uh the morality police
in Iran because she wasn't wearing her
hijab her head scarf correctly
um this is is quite a an extraordinary
moment in Iranian Society where that
there was initial unrest amongst people
who perhaps might be the obvious
candidates for protesting against the
government but now this has spread right
across Iran Beyond Kurdish areas and all
sorts of people older women are bearing
their hair and cutting their hair in
public
um the report in the telegraph today is
that there's an increase in people
um walking up to to clerics wearing
turbans and knocking their their
religious headgear from their heads
which is a huge Act of disrespect and
would have been utterly
a you know kind of appalling and
terrifying in previous days it's a huge
Act of courage and bravery to stand up
against
um the government yeah they've reported
that they're gonna
um put 900 people on trial they're
they're enacting a thing called
preventative arrests and in places where
there are big protests
um they're doing things like cutting off
uh internet connectivity so so people
are under kind of media blackouts and
it's extraordinary that people are still
protesting and I think the world's eyes
do need to be on Iran and I think our
support needs to be with the Iranian
people yeah so it should be further up
the papers it should be on the front
pages yeah although of course very
difficult to report from Iran at the
moment as well which we should mention
that but yes that they're you know as
much coverage as possible I agree it's a
very fascinating story and really
interesting to watch as it as it goes
ahead and let's move back to UK issues
Janelle because you've picked out a
story and I think it's the front pair
story actually in the Telegraph and they
and they pick up on it further inside as
well and this is about how Oxbridge
Oxford and Cambridge select their
students
yeah so they're using a different metric
so to speak and what they want to do is
they don't just want to look at the best
grades so to speak but they also want to
look at grades relative to students in
their own context and how they perform
against their peers you could say
they're looking for
um all rounded students in a culture fit
but to some people equality feels a bit
like oppression so some b-paying schools
are saying now the system is now biased
against students that attend fee paying
schools now for me I think it's very
um clear that a lot of students at fee
paying schools do have an extra
Advantage when it comes to filling in
those forms being able to show what they
know and all of those things and so the
fact that now the system is a bit more
rigorous a bit more competitive meaning
that other state students will have more
of an equal chance to get in I don't
think that they should see that as a
bias against them I think it's saying
okay look we want the brightest and the
best it's not just about grades but it's
also about students how well-rounded
they are what they contribute beats
University and I think that's brilliant
because we know that a lot of Oxbridge
students have positions of power in our
country they run a lot of things and
actually that should they should reflect
the whole of society and going through a
fee paying school or not shouldn't be
the only metric problem actually gives
you an advantage very good thoughts on
this Marianne I mean some people might
say well that's what grades are for to
be able to compare life with like I mean
what do you think do you think it's
better to go on on grades alone or to
delve deeper
so confession I went to Oxbridge I went
to Emmanuel College in Cambridge having
come from a state school and one of the
things that really struck me was that
not only did um people who were coming
from much wealthier backgrounds have all
the additional advantages sorry very
quickly Marianne we're running out of
time
sorry
um so uh no it needs to be much more
nuanced because it's not just about
grades it's about the rounded person
where they're coming from but also when
they get there they need the support so
that they don't feel like a massive Fish
Out of Water okay brilliant brilliantly
summarized thanks very much indeed
Marianne and Janelle I'll see you again
next now thank you
[Music]